yeah boy
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste I am your host for today
gone to joining me once again are the
boys how are you feeling guys you look
dead right now Corner yeah I woke up at
3 3 AM today so I'm a little tired
well sounds like a problem that uh you
brought upon yourself so this episode
I'm gonna be Joey I'm not gonna I'm
gonna be the like the adjudicator to the
artist okay okay
so that's I have to be you which means I
just have to spew [ __ ] for the next two
hours all right just shout and don't
listen but how am I going to like you
know that thing would you like I hate it
but how am I going to form an argument
not a good seat here
if that's not a conversation with Joey
it would just be like Joe you know what
and Joe you just like complete the
sentence yeah I was like yeah I agree I
agree no I totally agree yeah yeah I had
really spicy food as well and it was the
kind of spicy food that's a little too
spicy I still don't know what the [ __ ]
this spicy pea is this is a thing I
experienced it first time after the
charity live stream when I had that
ghost pepper when you have something
that is of ridiculous just yeah just
astronomical spiciness for some people
don't know why you can't say this out
loud a lot because it makes you sound
like you have an STD but you're like all
right I got spicy P my pee stings when I
pee and yeah just sometimes it's only
the first P yeah yeah it's only the
first P that's every subsequently
immediately after eating it yeah I don't
know what's going on there any p p
experts spice experts want to explain
you wanna you wanna like uh
yeah
what if if he drank spicy pea would it
actually be spicy oh that's the real
that's the real question I can't do it
yeah I don't know I've never experienced
ycp in my life yeah that's because
you're Thai are you sure you don't have
like I think your shoes sounds like a
painful thing no I'm fine I mean of
course it's painful but like what is it
okay get it getting deep
I I don't really understand how it works
it just does the thing yeah spicy spicy
food weird but uh guess you know you
know what I found weird recently now
that like I guess the country's opening
back up and we've complained for so many
backups oh well opening back up by the
time this episode's out it should be it
should be kind of completely open where
you don't even need to go on like one of
the North Korean tour guides
um you don't need a covert test
um and you can just come I'm not sure if
it'll be open for tourists by the time
this comes up but right now more people
that we know are coming in the country
yeah like recently we've obviously had
the safety third crew come on as you
know we've had a few of their members on
our podcast uh Kevin's finally being
gonna be able to come back as well yeah
everybody arrives like what is it like
two days before we all have to leave
exactly and I saw like a few more people
on Twitter that said oh finally you know
just landed in Japan or coming to Japan
yeah I'm like this is so [ __ ] weird
we've complained about this so long and
now people are actually coming in and
now I'm just like damn I don't really I
don't really have the time to show
people around anymore oh [ __ ] I realized
I offered too many people yeah of course
I'll show you around me yeah and then
they get here and I'm like actually you
know gone was making me record this
trash taste
why is God in the Instagram he's a
leader but like man's throwing you under
the bus I've been playing trash
I've just been blaming trash teeth
because I'm like well it's it's like the
boys you know I gotta prioritize work
sorry guys you know
that's the greatest that's the great
thing about trash taste because if if it
was just like your own channel then it's
on you you know you choose your own
schedule we're trash teeth we've got a
team I don't want to let the boys down
you know and they're like why don't you
want the rest of the boys I'm like oh
you know they're busy as well
yeah but uh yeah took the uh
safety third people out last weekend and
do you know what I realized
um after people have started coming in
where you're not gonna you're not gonna
experience this Joey because you already
are you already can speak Japanese but
because people are starting to come in
they everyone assumes that you're only
hunger Josie now because you've lived
here no but I mean I you speak a little
bit that sounds like a YouTuber like he
was doing a lot of speaking for me it
was I was doing a lot of asking a bunch
of questions when Emily first came here
as well I was talking a lot for her yeah
and on the first few days and she's like
she's like well you're so good at this
I'm like no no
say one thing yeah I'm guessing like I I
because I'm having like conversations
but obviously any conversation at all
when you don't speak the language seems
like nuts yeah yeah but when you're you
know when you when you're with someone
who understands it you're like bro why
are you doing like a two-year-old so
what you're telling me is that it was
the first time you actually felt like
you had to be the token translator yeah
yeah because because it was the first
time
you for the menus that are handwritten
can't you yeah but like the problem is
Joey I'm nowhere near even close to your
level but people are assuming that I am
your level so people so people people
like hanging out with them obviously
like first thing you do you go to the
taxi you tell them where to go and
people are like yo what the [ __ ] your
Japanese is so good and I'm like I
literally just said please stop here sir
here is okay please stop here yeah and
and then they get like a lot of people
ask me oh how do you say this in
Japanese how'd you say that in Japanese
and like some of the things I do know
but I know for a fact that there there
is like a Japanese way to say it and I'm
doing like the most Brute Force direct
translation I can think of of my like
baby Japanese yeah do you know what it
is though that I have found it's it's
not about like whether you have like an
extensive vocab or anything like that
it's I feel like confidence oh yeah it
shows such a long way no because like if
you confidently without like even a
shadow of a doubt walk up to a Japanese
person and just start speaking in the
most broken ass Japanese ever like oh me
hungry food like but if you say it with
absolute confidence like like a game
face and people see that they're just
like damn
yeah I had that happen yeah yeah that
was not good but it but it's bad right
because like sure it might look cool to
your Foreigner friends who don't know a
word of Japanese but then that Japanese
person will probably also to feel the
same way being like Oh damn this guy's
good at Japanese I'm just going to start
speaking at a normal pace and then the
moment they reciprocate to that you're
just like I'm like you know like because
being living in Japan you have certain
scripts for certain places yeah you've
heard it a million times it's like
playing a visual novel I wouldn't know
how that feels but I'm actually just
like you played like a million times you
know all the dialogue options and The
Roots yeah exactly well that's kind of
like learning languages in general you
know that's that's it's just picking up
patterns yeah you pick up patterns
um and if something goes out of that
pattern then you're kind of like a dear
panic because here's the thing right
normally you know when you're by
yourself you know sometimes you're just
not in the mood to go challenge yourself
to go out of your comfort zone or
something but when you're showing people
around Japan you got that pressure on of
course because I look around I'm like
surely there's someone morning hunger
Jersey than me no [ __ ] I'm the hunger
Josie guy here [ __ ] it's me that's got
to sort everything out okay I think it's
also worse when you're the one who like
reluctantly is like yeah I'll show you
guys around right and so you're already
suiting that like yeah yeah confidence
and then when you're actually in the
spot you're like [ __ ] I have to show
them around
I don't know what to do so so one thing
they were all looking for a place to eat
so um
where did you take them uh I took them
to an or you can eat uh Yakiniku place
okay yeah yeah because what I've
realized I asked Maylin where I should
take them and she gave me a bunch of
like recommendations and I was just like
I don't think this would be suitable for
a group of like 12. yeah right
everything becomes like 500 times harder
when you have more than six people in
Japan yeah oh easily yeah
you either have to go an all-you-can-eat
place or an Izakaya yeah it's like no
other choice yeah and I was just like
life hack you were cheering someone
around Japan they've never been to Japan
for if they've been here once go to an
all you can eat place and that will
impress them yeah you know just it's so
it's so easy yeah
Japanese hot pot or you can eat and
that's like it's insane I've never even
been there before have you not no bro
it's so good there's like a there's like
a billion of them in Shinjuku yeah I was
impressed dude it's nuts it's like 40
bucks no it's not even 40 bucks 40 four
thousand yen to like 30 something bucks
yeah you can and then you get all you
can eat as much food as you want and
then all you want all you can drink for
two hours it's like eight dollars or
something or like ten bucks
it's actually just like what are we
doing exactly how are these places
making money I I I I that's because they
don't know that's because they don't you
know they're not used to foreigners I
think because the big thing sound do
music exactly because the big thing I've
noticed especially after taking more
people out to all you can eat places is
that when Japanese people here all you
can eat it's all you want to eat when
you hear like an America when you change
it to all you can eat yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what do you take an
American or a British person or most
people in the west to an all you can eat
place it is a challenge right it is not
a all you want or you're comfortable to
eat it is how much can my stomach expand
before like how how quickly can I
bankrupt this place to make them feel
like they made them the biggest mistake
of their life to make something called
all you can eat that is true actually
like I've been to enough Buffets in
Vegas now to know that like seeing like
seeing Americans in a buffet is like you
think like the apocalypse is coming
where they're just like I was like are
you about to fast for three days like
why are you eating so much I don't even
enjoy it like yeah I just I get to a
point where I'm like full and I'll just
push like 30 beyond that yeah just
because I'm like well
I may as well and it's like but yeah no
other situation would I ever order this
much for you no I would I would have cut
it off like years ago yeah man so so
like we went to this all week in a
yakaniki place and immediately we sit we
sit down and I haven't I haven't like
had this mindset in a while but
immediately they start asking me
questions right because they start
asking me what the rules of the game are
you know like okay hypothetically if we
over order by hypothetically
hypothetically speaking if we over order
by four plates of food will they charge
us for it and I'm like I I don't I don't
really know because that's never really
happens but I mean I'm sure you could
play The Foreigner card and so they're
like great that's all we need to know
they order like a [ __ ] ton of food and
like here's the thing normally this all
you can eat Yakiniku plays they have
like it's like real coals right so
normally uh this restaurant have placed
enough coals in this barbecue to last
you for about the two hours right
normally it's it's like perfectly timed
so you have enough time to eat the food
and then by the time the two hour ends
the calls we kind of died out well
that'll be fine because you're like
you'll be like oh I'll take like one
more plate or something like that yeah
not not with these guys so we we get to
like an hour and a half in and the
waiter comes over and it's just like oh
last order's in about like five ten
minutes would you like to order anything
else
um
like it was like me Sydney uh Liberty
who's a Content producer you know that
there's like you know the more Japanese
Centric table that have that you have
that Common Sense acclimated with the
culture and then there's the boys on the
other side the safety third boys they
hear the last orders coming in and
they're they're like um can we order
like 10 more plates and also can we
change the coals and I think it would it
wasn't ordering the 10 more plates yeah
it was the request to change the calls
right right because I don't like I don't
think in the history of this
establishment anyone's asked to change
the calls 30 minutes before last orders
are coming in they're like the wage is
like what you you want me to you want me
to change the calls what what I I don't
understand why don't you why do you want
to change the calls and so there's
there's us there's us the Japanese
residence on one side just being like
I'm so full I'm so full and then there's
the American boys on the other side 15
minutes in and they're getting like 10
more plates of meat I'm like how the F
how are you doing this what the [ __ ] so
did they did they even like put a dent
in that or they [ __ ] finished it they
it like like I said it was a challenge
it wasn't he like it was it was they
wanted to make a statement right they
wanted to make a statement that this
establishment was a [ __ ] idiot right
they love breaking news yeah yeah
they're like if I'm not bankrupting this
place then uh then I've done something
wrong no wonder all you can eat places
don't [ __ ] last in the US yeah I feel
like that's a mindset thing that we get
like born into like I I the first time I
went to all you can eat in Japan I I
know you can drink I'm like I gotta I
gotta I'm taking this I'm taking the
weights off yeah I'm going in yeah and I
don't know why like why do I immediately
hear a reasonably priced buffet and I'm
like instead of making this into a
normal meal where I'm probably gonna get
my money's worth anyway I'm just gonna
try and ruin myself and ruin this such a
weird psychology isn't it because it's
like there's no pressure it's not like
you're losing money yeah I think also
like a big thing is just when you're
obviously they're traveling around when
you're just in Holiday mode oh the rules
you know holiday mode the rules are off
you know you're not trying to look after
you I'm sure it will be the opposite if
we went to the US yo actually there's
Buffets in Vegas look insane I've heard
them Fox yeah they're like like Gourmet
buffets or something yeah only America
would they want to bastardize food there
man so they're like let's do it yeah
like when we went to LA I went to so
many [ __ ] all you can eat Korean
barbecues because that's the one [ __ ]
thing one [ __ ] thing I miss about La
which is the Korean barbecue there is
amazing
um and I you know like luckily or
unluckily the rules are a bit more
strict there because they have a bit
more people who are let's say over order
so they're like you have to you'd have
to have those rules yeah if you if you
they're like if you order like one play
over we're gonna charge you I've noticed
that actually not a lot of Japanese I
think I've been to like maybe one place
where they like charge you if you don't
finish your food that you order extra
off but like for the most part yeah I
think Japanese people are more sensible
and being like I'll order what I can eat
yeah a lot of places where I'll probably
just like if you're like one plate left
over they're like ah all right yeah all
right but obviously you know I'm just
thinking like I'm just thinking of the
situation that both that rule yeah you
know like what what what person went to
like an all-you-can-eat Korean barbecue
it's just like oh yeah so you kind of
just left like 40 kilograms of meat on
and I remember like it's normally right
obviously Jackie niku writes poles and
stuff so there's a lot of smoke yes yeah
um we go there at like five o'clock at
just open middle of nowhere inside to
Martin legit middle of nowhere right um
and we go in and this is pretty big
restaurant for where what I thought was
a big ration for where it was so we walk
in
and the staff are immediately like whoa
foreign
cook the food yep and I noticed that
like the fan isn't on to like suck out
all the the smoke yeah yeah and so I'm
like I'm like oh I'm like should we ask
him Chris to turn it on it's like it's
kind of a lot of smoke yeah and the guy
comes over and we're like hey um could
you could you could you turn the fan on
and he's like yeah of course just walks
away
and then and then I it starts to kind of
build up yeah and I suddenly look around
the corner and there's just smoke
everywhere in this building okay right
and I'm like when are they gonna come
come over and turn the fan on I don't
know how to turn the fan on it was like
a really old Antiquated fan and then
eventually they're like oh did you turn
the fan off we're like no they're like
why is it off like it was never on I
just thought I'd put the blame on you
and mastered it did we turn it off and
we were like no no no no no they seem
like sus about it and they were like
never again foreigners never again right
all [ __ ] foreigners
they were literally just smoking out the
place and they took like [ __ ] 20
minutes to realize and I just felt
really bad and I was like why why did
this happen this is why phone is online
it wasn't like an old building or like
an old yeah it's pretty old yeah no I
mean yeah dude I did that [ __ ] I [ __ ]
up and did that thing by the way the
confidence Japanese thing got it wrong
yeah not really I feel like you need to
though oh yeah dude I well no I did it
the other day oh um because I was we
just done like trash taste I was tired
and we went to the place uh like this
Izakaya with uh safety third people yeah
a bunch of other people and they were
like oh how many oysters is it on the
picture and there was there's a picture
and it's like a bunch of oysters like
six of them in one plate and it was like
600 Yen and I was like oh
um I was like I don't know I don't think
it's 600 Yen for six oysters that's
pretty cheap especially in this kind of
restaurant yeah yeah oh yeah don't worry
I'll ask them
woman comes over I'm like oh swimming
which is uh how long
oh yeah how long are the oysters yeah
yeah and she was like what but I was
super confident about it like confidence
100. and then she just told me
and then she went
she looked like she literally went like
what and then went
and I was like oh okay well I got my
answer
and I was like I was like did I did I
did you say it was like 600 Yen for one
um
she was like mental arithmetics
yeah and so I was like guys it's it's
600 Yen for an oyster and they're like
oh you're amazing I was like guys
no I would say like if there's been one
big motivator for wanting to learn more
Japanese now is now having people come
in and being like oh you got to be the
hunger Josie person now because
um same thing happened to me actually
where where we have we had this uh they
were looking for a place to eat you know
beforehand and it's hard to find a place
for 12 people and so 12 yeah 12. there's
12 years yeah there was 12 of us right I
would have I literally told a bunch of
people I was like can we split this up
like yeah this is not happening like
we're not getting in anywhere we have
two unless you don't book ahead of time
you did one day yeah yeah so that's
that's the thing that's why I chose um I
forgot the I I forgot the name of the
place but the yakaniki place I chose was
a brand you know it was a chain
it's uh there's only a few Q yeah
not Georgian I I forgot what it was but
I remember phoning up
I remember finding one of the branches
and I was phoning up and asking if they
had space for 12.
um and they did you know it was it was
it was all good you know I was like no
way as he did yeah yeah they did they
did I was like I was like confidently I
I can I can [ __ ] do this all of my
years in Japan have built up to this
moment I can do this I like it's I've
I've booked tables before I've like I'm
very satisfying yeah yeah very satisfied
booking tables
um I kind of know the script and I kind
of know how to go off scripted just in
case so I asked if they have space for
12. they go great I ask if we can split
into tables just in case because it's a
big group and they're like that's that's
no problem at all
um I asked for the time I asked for 6 30
and uh they said they don't have a space
for 6 30. uh can you do space at 8 30
and I'm like sure that's okay
um and then they said something that I
didn't understand and I was like [ __ ] I
was like what's so important [ __ ] I was
doing doing so well and you know you
know how you know how when how does the
game of Pluto began
thus the Sherlock game begins right so
your kids here's here's what it's like
being not exactly you know learning a
language and knowing some words for not
knowing the entire context of what's
being said you recognize some words and
within that you try to infer what
they're trying to say now normally this
is much easier when you're in person
because you've got you know body
language you've got hand signals you've
got more context clues it's ten times
harder on the phone right uh because
you've got you got nothing but just you
know your listening skills
and so what I heard was I heard uh can I
confirm and I and uh and she said which
one and then something I was like [ __ ]
what is what is she trying to confirm
with me and I was just like I remember
browsing through their menu and I was
and they had like different tiers for
whichever menu you wanted this or you
need to be yeah so I was like great it
must be that one and I was like can I
have the menu That's the middles the
middle uh the middle menu please
and she was like and [ __ ] I heard a PO I
heard a pause
and I was like oh no
oh no not Instagram I was like I have
chosen the wrong dialogue I'm correct I
have chosen the wrong dialogue option
[ __ ] and she was like uh no no I and she
she tries and then here's where like
goes here's like if I'd chosen the right
dialogue option it's like great [ __ ]
great genius no hunger josu hello yeah I
choose the wrong dialogue option I've
opened up another dialogue tree with
even more complex dialogue options and
I've just gotten myself into a [ __ ]
mess you've opened up the explanation
you found the Elden ring boss
basically so she says uh no no no no
um just uh and and then she she starts
going into even more complex like goes
into detail it goes into detail about it
and I just like I understand even less
and so my Panic brain just goes yes
in English no no I go hey I should have
started with the high yeah yeah that's
just like my default that's everything
that's that's my default dialogue and
that works I would say 80 it works a
shocking amount yeah this was one of the
times where it didn't work and she was
like uh
[Music]
goes off away for a minute and I'm like
oh [ __ ] what did I just say yes to what
did I just say yes to like would you
like to buy shares in our company
you want to get a mortgage
I'm sorry she goes off for five for five
minutes and then she comes back and she
starts she starts like spewing me the
entire [ __ ] gospel she starts getting
to me like the entire Holy Bible and
then she ends is that okay and I'm like
no yes and then and then and then and
then she was like okay so just to
confirm you just agree to all of these
things
can I can I put you down and I'm like
yes and then and then she goes and then
I'm gonna go and then I go and then she
goes great
hangs up the phone the first thing I
immediately do is uh hit up our intern
Kai and just be like Kai can you find up
this place and just confirm that I
actually made a [ __ ] booking
and then I find out what she was trying
to confirm with me was I thought by
phoning this specific number yeah that
it would go straight to the restaurant
right but because it was a branch she
was trying to confirm which branch
which I've I've never been asked I've
never heard that before I've never been
awesome weird as [ __ ] yeah I've never
been asked that question before did you
phone up like the company or like
I I don't know I just phoned up the uh
because normally if you go on Google
Maps and you yeah yeah the location and
the number is specifically for the
building yeah yeah exactly yeah I've
never heard of that before yeah
I was just like guys I think I [ __ ] up
but I don't want to look bad in front of
my friends uh can you guys save me
please he's like you guys sleep that's
why I like it when the Google Maps has
the reservation option in Japan that's
oh yeah I love this so much no no like
it like this Branch had a reservation
option but not for more than six people
which is why which is why like I knew
this one phone call was gonna push my
language ability level yeah to to its
limit at the time and you know I was
doing I was there so well I was this
close I was this one yeah
stall I've never heard of that that's
like doing a boss battle and then you
think you've beaten them and then the
phase two starts yeah he's like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] there's more
[ __ ] oh yeah see I I'm I'm like kind of
in a sense I'm kind of jealous though
because I haven't experienced that yet
because I'm not I'm I'm not good nor bad
enough at a current language where I can
try to attempt to do certain things yeah
it's either I know the language or I
know nothing about the language yeah so
I want to get to a point where I'm kind
of like in the Middle where you guys are
where it's like you're on the cusp of
going from I'm learning the language to
I can speak it conversationally yeah so
it's like I don't know I've always
wanted to learn a third language I mean
I mean like I've got like the Joey
experience once in my life where I was
able to like yeah the Joey experience
yeah yeah when we're in LA and we went
to the Thai restaurant and I think it
was like the first ever time I've been
to a Thai restaurant with these boys
because you never you're like every time
for this [ __ ]
I always I'm like gone where do I where
do we go nowhere nowhere in Thailand
[ __ ] there's got to be some good
Thai food here no but a Thai food in La
really good because they have like
actual so many more options than you can
find in restaurants in like the UK and
stuff and so I was like great you know
able to like ask you know Flex My Thai
you know asking you know give give us a
good stuff just give us a good question
that's the most I've ever heard you
speaking tonight yeah yeah but I I
didn't know what you were saying but I
would just like to imagine that you were
like bring me the real menu not this
[ __ ] right here I know you have it
somewhere back there
the only thing I was asking was yes I
was asking for things actually not on
the menu and they I was asking if they
have it they said yes I was like uh give
me give me like your menu give me like
the Thai Spice don't don't give me like
I don't feel like the baby foreign
yeah yeah it felt good it's the best
feeling this episode is sponsored by
Honey the easy way to save When shopping
on your iPhone or Computer Boys how do
you feel about shopping online love it
do it every day of course is there any
other way to do it aside from online I'm
gonna go outside but how often do you
feel like you have the promo code ready
at the checkout well you know what guys
thanks to Honey manually searching for
coupon codes are a thing of the past
thank God honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one of the
fines to your cars come on what have you
saved on honey I recently acquired a
brand new desk and thanks to honey I
saved twenty dollars twenty dollars
that's a meal that's a steal and best of
all honey was easy to use it is so easy
to use in fact that honey doesn't just
work on your desktop did you know it
works on your iPhone too just activated
on Safari on your phone and you can save
on the go if you don't already have
honey you could be straight out missing
out on savings guys am I getting it
you're doing yourself a favor and
sporting us as well so what are you
waiting for go to joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joinhoney.com trash taste
back to the episode since uh since you
know finally the pandemic's dying down
more events are opening up here in Japan
as well uh I finally got to go to my
first summer Mad City my first Summer
Festival oh yeah and uh real anime
moment I assume yeah okay here's how his
I won down right
so uh I get back to Japan after
traveling from Australia and didas and
Emily hit me up being like yo we're
going to a Summer Festival and of course
huh and of course you know didus and
Emily they hear Summer Festival they see
this as an anime moment they want to go
all out right so so there's this big
group that consists of like a lot of
like Geeks plus talent and Geeks plus
staff mailing was there as well and
everyone's like guys we're finally
having a Summer Festival episode [ __ ]
yeah okay we've got to go all [ __ ]
out so we go out to like rent yukatas
for the day like I think like Malin had
to travel like an hour or something or
wait an hour to like rent her Yukata she
you know in Mainland fashion shows up
like two hours late or some [ __ ] of
course um I had to like travel you know
travel like half an hour to get to my
closest yukato rental place
um I'm really excited we all like meet
up
and then we go to the Summer Festival
and it was the most like
there was a Japanese if if there was an
in between a special in Japan this would
be it like we how it went in our head
was we imagined every [ __ ] single
Summer Festival episode of anime that
we've seen you know we got like we got
like the events going on it's like in a
nice school you know it's it's like in a
nice spacious park or a nice spacious
place you've got you got the gym the
weird sexual tension the fireworks and
everything
um so we go to this place yeah and it's
in a [ __ ] car park right
[Music]
oh sorry
sorry guys not not a car park a
basketball court okay so even smaller
yeah it was [ __ ] tiny right it was it
was a basketball court next to this
train station right it was like it was
so so we had we we went in and it was it
was Tiny all right I was expecting us to
be able to like walk around there'd be
like different events there'd be
different shops I was waiting to get
like my [ __ ] yucky sober get my like
shaved ice you know play that [ __ ]
minigame where you like shoot uh shoot
the thing pick up the ball pick up the
ball pick up the Goldfish and [ __ ] like
that I was waiting for that there was
none of that none of that right there
was one stand for shaved ice and that
was the longest queue of this entire
Festival right right it was even a
festival at that point or is it a
glorified
Street show
I mean it kind of was just okay I went
to like the Compton of summer festivals
basically basically we were me and like
all of us are starting there we spend
more time waiting for our yukatas than
it would have taken to go through
everything in this [ __ ] Festival
right this this festival and we were
just waiting in line to get our like
yakisoba and as we're waiting in this
line because there was like gated off
and we see like railway tracks and every
like 10 10 minutes of the show uh 10
minutes or so we'd have this like really
you know it wasn't even like atmospheric
right because every 10 minutes or so
you'd have the train going
laughs
I know and I was just like I got [ __ ]
dressed up for this so so why did you go
to this one another good one uh because
apparently like all the good ones are
way like you have to travel like an hour
or two outside of the city yeah
yeah I saw a big one not too far from
where I live that was decently way
bigger than the one you guys sent
there's a couple of big ones I've been
to as well but the problem is is that
it's either way too incredibly packed
yeah or especially during like the
covert season they like really limit the
space true yeah the amount of people so
like the the they sometimes like ticket
these places now yeah so it's like you
can't just like rock up to these places
anymore yeah so this place was
incredibly small and also incredibly
packed oh yeah yeah
um there was like
how sweaty were you I was oh it was so
[ __ ] sweaty okay there's poor rentals
yeah yeah you must have given them a
[ __ ] like damp rag bro I'm pretty
sure they had to incinerate all of our
you know I felt so bad right and I
wasn't even like the most sweaty one
there was like everyone was like
sweating through their [ __ ] colors
I'm I'm so glad that they give you like
space between like your pets because
holy [ __ ] if if if it was like a t-shirt
like it would our pits would be would
have been absolutely [ __ ] stained
gross and I was like there was like one
long line I was hoping this was like
actually something cool maybe it was
like a mini game or something yeah um
like I could see everyone lining up to
this one [ __ ] queue yeah and I was
like oh cool maybe you know you didn't
know what you're lining up for no but
you just joined a line I I I joined the
line for like five minutes and I thought
I thought it must have been British
people when they try and have fun
it might it must be something cool it
must be something that was fun yeah that
was funny I I joined in life and then I
realized wait all right I realized five
minutes in I should probably check what
this line is for so I get Sydney over
Sydney wait here in line just in case
it's something cool yeah maybe it's like
maybe it's like one of the shooty games
somebody's like the Goldfish thing I go
up right and this is by far the longest
line where you'd have to wait in line
for about 30 minutes to get to the front
[ __ ] balloon
balloon kids can go there and buy
balloons
and kids were waiting 30 plus minutes to
go to this one stall to buy balloons and
that was the highlight of this Festival
now that's not even like traditionally
Japanese you can you can get a [ __ ]
you can do that at Disneyland as well
they sell one dollars
it wasn't even like a paper balloon like
just like a regular ass like plastic
balloon or
a lot it's like the stall was like it's
literally touchable so basically so once
you like you get like
you know I wanted to go to this last
year but I was sick but I think I dodged
it bullet you kind of did actually so we
we actually we went we went there we
stayed for like 30 minutes and
immediately like we were like can we
leave just 30 minutes yeah because it
was literally there was nothing to do
there there was literally nothing to do
that and uh the only reason we stayed
was because mailing was like an hour
late so we're like oh I guess we gotta
wait for May Lin uh but there was like
one Saving Grace to this Festival
which is uh it wasn't there well there
was nothing happening at the beginning
but there was a stage where you know
where music was being played and
everything like that the dance around it
yeah where they dance around it is is
there a name for that can you explain
what the tradition is like uh yeah so
they're basically at the bigger
festivals what they do is uh they build
this giant really really high stage
usually it's like I don't know five ten
meters up in the air yeah
um and then they do this dance usually
at the end of the festival where they
light a fire
um and then there are stage performers
up on stage and then basically everyone
around them they're just dancing like in
a clockwise like kind of circle dance
yeah yeah it's probably one of the most
like common types of festivals like
there's some [ __ ] wacky festivals out
there but I'd say that's probably the
most common one yeah so there was
something there was there was one at
this Festival that we went to and there
was nothing happening really on stage
when we first arrived yeah but when
Malin arrived that's when they started
you know the whole dance kind of thing
the whole music the whole traditional
dance and traditional music and
initially I was just like what the [ __ ]
is this I've already had like an awful
time here I just want to leave go
somewhere air conditioned cool off yeah
[ __ ] get this sweat off yeah and the
mail is like no no go check out the
dolls come on I just got here I was like
fine mailing come on let's go let's go
check out the dance then okay whatever
and
so so there's so
so there's this guys they're playing
this traditional song and they're doing
this traditional dance up on stage this
is the one that's like that one yeah
yeah yeah like like like that one oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh and I mean
they had like everyone up on stage had
like traditional yukatas on except
there's one Grandma who they you know
they have fans of course in the Summer
Festival
um it was really weird just seeing one
traditional grandma in a traditional
Yukata and then she was sporting a Cars
2 fan
you know what nothing's this Summer
Festival quite like Lightning McQueen
that's Japan man tradition mixed with uh
you know Captain and the Disney
Corporation it's just like saying
they're seeing this traditional dance
just seeing like Lightning McQueen just
up there if it was minions it would have
been more on brands
minions but uh yeah initially no one no
one wanted to like join in and dance
because it was like it's hot it's summer
everyone's sweating but then we had this
for like one we called him like the
alpha right there's there's there was
this one alpha yeah who just got got
down off the stage and like rallied the
crowd together right and he was like he
just did the dance of such confidence
that you see one person joining him then
two people then like somehow he just
conjures up an entire [ __ ] line yeah
of people just like dancing around the
states what a child yeah what what
absolute chat yeah and then I remember
for one song he had to like go to the
toilet or something and like without the
alpha everyone was lost we were like
like I remember because we so you were a
sheep as well yeah we were sheep we were
all of your sheep you're literally just
like a [ __ ] flock of sheep after the
Sheepdog is like where do we go what do
we do yeah because it was uh it was it
was me Sydney didus mailing just like
following this guy following his dance
he leaves for a second we're like
what do we do we we are lost the music
hasn't stopped uh uh uh
just a fortnight dance
and so we do this for like half an hour
45 minutes yeah and we think all right
kind of had enough music stops and the
next ACT is coming on
um so we're getting ready to leave and
they announced the next ACT
uh and let's just say this was not the
Japanese summer Festival experience I
was expecting because the next ACT they
bring on
they announced them and they're like
please into introducing Bobby and I'm
like bubbly that does not sound like a
traditional Japanese like music act what
is this [ __ ] Idol group comes on
they say hello we are bubbly let's
[ __ ] get it boys let's go let's go
and they start doing a dance and somehow
in this Summer Festival it turns to an
Idol concert right
people have the little things we should
have right yeah because that's that's
people you people were using their
[ __ ] fans instead of like because I
was saying we they're Lightning McQueen
fans well you know they do that they why
did the visual cave video they also used
fans yeah yeah because I don't know yeah
so if you've been to another concert
normally people have like the glowy
sticks where they do like the glowy
dance so they had that kind of dance
they were trying they were trying to get
people to like join along with but they
everyone just kind of used their [ __ ]
fans to like join along and it was like
the most okay here's how you could tell
who the Brits in the crowd were okay so
there was like so everyone was like kind
of like going along with their stance
going along with this Idol concert
um and then I I was like ah this is this
is this is a bit too much for me this is
very this is this this is not getting
paid for yeah this ain't it for me and
so I like step back and I look to my
left and who would I see I see
um
I see that only two other Brits in Geeks
plus just standing alongside me
we had all thoughts subconsciously
thought the same thing and we all had
all taken a step back and just was like
no no
[Laughter]
that's so funny sometimes you're just in
the in the vibe and you're like no yeah
yeah no no there's a time and place for
that kind of stuff and just that day was
not the day meanwhile meanwhile died
it's right at the front of the Hugo yeah
let's go bubbly bubbly let's go
it was like the most surreal experience
I had ever seen because
um because you could tell like there
there was like some fans in the crowd
that were like hardcore fans you know
they knew every dance they knew all of
the lyrics and they were like spread out
in the crowd like they were like like
they were purposely there to like
indoctrinate people right because
because it was like a proper Idol
concert and then I turned to May Lin and
I was like this is my first Japanese
Festival this is my is this is this
traditional and she just tells me and
goes no
I I don't know what's going on and
remind me again this is all happening on
a [ __ ] basketball court this is
happening
to give me allow me to paint a better
picture of this how many people were at
this thing would you yeah how big was
this basketball because basketball
courts can't hold more like 100 people
yeah
I said three basketball courts yeah so I
thought that's still tiny so you know
when you're in school there was a
playground I had like a basketball court
and maybe something else oh no actually
like a soccer field yeah the stage was
actually on the tennis court I think so
how how many people were at this Summer
Festival I'd say 300. [ __ ] fair amount
for yeah for that size no no it was a
tiny space and it was absolutely packed
to the brim full of nothing
full of nothing I'm a shaved ice
balloons and yeah it was great I went to
a Summerfest full got a free Idol
concerts no I don't think I don't think
you should say you went to a Summer
Festival because from the sounds of it
you didn't go to a Subway you weren't
sure you went to an uh a Summer Festival
themed Idol concert yeah yeah no no guys
I went to it like I you know you know
how I got on my mind my money's worth
out of that Summer Festival I took one
picture I posted it on Twitter got a
hundred a hundred thousand likes I was
like guys I went to
if people believe I went to a Summer
Festival that's what's important when I
saw that picture I was like I was
imagining you know I saw a lot of people
behind I was just like oh wow this must
be like a really massive summer vessel
if I really I'd seen outside of the
frame and seeing that it doesn't extend
that much perfectly framed it so we were
like you know frame out the train frame
and like frame out the basketball court
just make it look like it's a it's a
good Summer Festival how much did it
cost you to rent your ucata
oh [ __ ] I don't remember it was like I
mean so a lot of places can be 80. yeah
a lot of places can be a bit expensive
you paid 60 or 80 bucks to get sweaty
yeah for like what two hours three hours
yeah two three hours yeah
we just want to karaoke afterwards and
uh uh and uh that was that was the
highlight because it was like yeah you
counter huh in your you guys yeah yeah
oh my God that sounds like a lot of work
it's basically just PJs except it's
socially acceptable I I'm like giggle
white so it it looks weird I'm not sure
when you wear it it just looks like lost
Samurai cosplay I do I do look like
every Facebook photo actually it was so
funny right because when we when we rock
up we had this whole Geeks plus crew
that rocked up to the Summer Festival
yeah like I said we all dressed up for
it we rock up to the Summer Festival
look around and I'm like guess who the
foreigners were they were the ones
wearing the yukatas so it was like
everyone else is just normal yeah
everyone else was dressed normally so
that was that was like the Japanese
people all dressing in just like normal
clothes it's like just like normal
clothes then there was the foreigners
there was a group of us just rocking up
in our uconnis and we were just like
[ __ ] guys we weren't the only ones who
actually dressed up for this I guarantee
all the Japanese people there were like
how do we tell them that it's just
accidentally turned up in a text to an
elementary graduate like that's what
can't do it was that one time where you
you get like the Halloween party invite
and you're like I should dress up for
this yeah you were the only one who
dressed up to this Halloween party
that's the experience we had oh my god
well no yeah it was uh I I almost
hearing that story I almost want to take
you guys to like an actual problem no I
want to go to a problem yeah yeah let's
go somewhere like in the middle of
nowhere oh yeah the ones in the middle
of nowhere nowhere near Tokyo have you
guys ever been to like any other like
types of festivals because I think I
feel as much as as much fun as those
summer festivals are the most fun I've
ever I've ever had at festivals are the
ones that are just [ __ ] bonkers the
penis one well the penis Festival as
well I mean I did a video on that that
was insane yeah what what is the history
behind that Festival I don't [ __ ]
know I mean it's like a fertility thing
I need it yeah yeah it's the celebrate
fertility and it's basically think of
like think of uh I think the only way I
can describe it right is like so there's
many of them all over the place uh the
one that I went so I think was like the
biggest one that they do every year and
it basically starts off with like this
parade on the streets there were many
penis festivals yes yeah yeah in
different parts of Japan I thought no I
did I thought I thought when you said
many festivals I just thought you meant
many Japanese festivals no no there are
many penis vessels throughout the year
damn they are they praying hard to that
penis yeah I do they need it they need
more they need it this is literally like
how do we stop this thing thoughts and
prayers
actual we do something yeah so like the
one I went to was the biggest one I
forgot whereabouts it was uh somewhere
like closer to Nagoya I think oh no it
wasn't nowhere uh or aichi
um that one's wild that one was huge uh
and the and the penis yeah and like some
of these like there's basically like a
parade that happens where everyone's
like lined up on the side of the streets
and then they bring in a bunch of like
traditional
um you know penis shaped objects
and they finish it off with the
girthiest schlong I've ever seen in my
life it's this like wooden schlong I
want to guess it's maybe about 15 meters
long what carried no The Good the girth
is probably I know many people to carry
this thing like 40 guys it's like
[ __ ] Johnny Sins equivalence there's
40 guys carrying Johnny since [ __ ] and
and they and they carry it through the
the parade uh you know they stole
through people I don't know at the
temple I guess she's got like a storage
unit somewhere and then they they walk
it through the parade you know people
taking photos whatever and then they
prop it up in front of the Temple
so at the end of the festival there's
just this giant 50 meter wooden [ __ ]
just just like sitting there in front of
the temple and then at the end of the
the one I went to they did this
tradition I don't know what the the the
the you know the history behind it is
but it's really dangerous and this is
the only one that they do it at uh they
what they do is they go up on these like
this giant stage that's built up about
5-10 meters tall so kind of like the one
you saw yeah at the Summer Festival
except instead of a square one it's like
a long rectangle right um and there's
about
10 15 dudes who are standing at the top
of this thing with a basket full of
Mochi right and I'm not talking about
the squishy Emoji right I'm talking
about oh like the the [ __ ] you put
before it's cooked [ __ ] in these plastic
bags yeah and what they do is they just
grab handfuls of this [ __ ] and they just
Chuck it into the crowd
and these people are just like
desperately trying to catch these Mochi
well what's really dangerous about it is
that if you're not careful because
there's literal tens of hundreds of
[ __ ] Mochi pieces yeah flying out and
these are Big these are like size of my
fist right kid dies if you if you're not
careful that thing can smack you in the
[ __ ] head and it and I got smacked in
the head you've got a deck an old
grandma yeah I was I was filming it in
my video and I got decked in the [ __ ]
forehead by one I'm just like pow and
then since then he didn't watch anime
and then place it back trace it back and
then it was just like and I was like
what's anime where am I what but I think
I think the craziest one I went to
though was in nagana was that opinions
no not the penis one uh the one I went
to in Nagano was uh the fire Festival
not the fire Festival that's a different
one this one happened not fyre internet
restoring video yeah I know that one not
fyre Festival the f-i-r-e festival
um
yes also it's extremely dangerous okay
so basically what they do is they build
this giant 20 25 meter wooden like
teepee looking structure right and
people are gathered all around it and
then what happens is they set it on fire
and then there are people in the back
who push the crowd towards the fire what
why
I don't know but basically if you're
standing in the front you are getting
cooked alive and you're trying to fight
back all these like people trying to
basically push you into a fight it's
like it's like Mass witch hunting
Korean squid game we had to get people
who are broke games
and I was and and mind you right this is
like there are like hundreds of people
just all gathered around and there's and
when this thing sets a blaze yeah it's
just this massive bonfire so you could
be like 20 25 meters away from this
thing and it's hot as [ __ ] yeah I can't
I can't imagine what it's like it's
literally fire yeah it's literally fire
it's like if there was a house on fire
and then someone and you were watching
it and then someone behind you was like
get close that's what it was like it's
like no I don't want to get close to
that thing it's hot I they do that for
some reason I want to say that like yeah
no we don't have any weird festivals but
we have that one but we Chase like
cheese down the hill Oh that one's the
dumbest Festival of all time that's
dangerous that's like [ __ ] up is that
the one where they push the wheels of
cheese now push the wheel of cheese and
people just [ __ ] [ __ ] like flip
down the hill to try and get it first
yeah so so they have like an ambulance
on call and any Festival yeah where you
have an ambulance on call is never a
good sign oh yeah
um and so the right it's like the wheel
cheese wheel rolling Festival where you
just like you they you have a big wheel
of cheese roll it down like a very very
steep hill and they have a festival
where people try to chase the wheel yeah
whoever gets whoever touches it wins
whoever touches it first wins no is
there any way you can catch up to that
thing though uh yeah there's like some
people who are in insane and literally
like throw their bodies yeah they don't
care wow so how people normally go is if
you run Fallout full speed down a hill
is normally your body can't trip your
body can't keep up with the moment right
so either you're going to fall flat on
your face or you're just going to start
rolling or most of the time you're going
to get some kind of broken bone or some
injury because that's what happens when
you run full force down a hill isn't
that isn't that like that scene in Bucky
where he's like full bolting it down the
stairs and he's like this is boring and
he starts yawning but there's probably
one dude in that Festival who's like
that where he's like yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] though and just all for some cheese
the part of me is like I want to at
least be there yeah I want to see people
just like eat [ __ ] yeah I think that's
the whole point right yeah I think
that's why people love it yeah I don't
I'm pretty sure the local government is
like please can we stop doing the cheese
thing and they're like no what's the
what's the tradition behind it though
like why do they do it oh I don't know I
know it's something that is like the the
origins are very murky yeah it's not
like I feel every Festival is like it's
not it's not like this is 100 what
happened I feel like I've heard it
before because there's a Netflix
documentary about weird things more of
the episodes is about it because um yeah
because I know for a fact that in Japan
at least the reason why we do festivals
or Matsuri is I think like there's
theories that like they used to be used
for like sacrificial rituals and [ __ ]
like that and then one day someone was
like let's take the sacrificial part out
and maybe just like dance instead I just
have a good stop
[Laughter]
supervised
that's the cool sign yeah I watched a Qi
thing and it was talking about like
[ __ ] uh Japanese like celibate monks
or something and they were like they
would like have to it was wild like what
they would do it was like something when
you were when you were done with your
duties to prove that you were loyal to
like the monk HUD you would just trap
yourself in like a coffin for like 80
days and just die oh you were not
allowed to come out and if you came out
as a sign of weakness they put them in
like a ditch right like a whole
something like I can't remember the
exact thing but it's like what is like
the the dedication yeah to this [ __ ] in
Japan is like next oh yeah because I
remember I I saw like a similar video
recently where they were talking about
this like uh I guess like type of like
monk uh training that you can do called
usheri and basically they do this thing
called the Thousand day walk oh and
basically what they do is every day you
walk between I think it's like 30 to
kilometers through the mountains and
meditate and you do that for a thousand
days but it's so hardcore that when you
sign up for this thing they actually
give you a small knife where if you
don't succeed in it you have to
literally set puku
a lot of them
and I'm just like bro bro like how far
down do you have to be to be like I'm
gonna do this I really want to find the
celebration it's crazy and this and it's
still a thing that they do today that's
insane yeah it's not and there are just
people who do that that's that's they
literally they literally said so you
have chosen death yeah it's like we will
it's like would you like to be
enlightened please walk for a thousand
days straight
that's literally like a Hunter x Hunter
test you know that yeah
if by the end of the Thousand Days you
don't have Nan like it's not exactly
yeah like it's not worth it that's part
of the hunter exam you know you get your
hunter's license after this or you die
you know that's that's literally that's
I wouldn't be surprised and some of you
will die yeah someone ran a little too
much on time I was like yeah we can do
that it was tagashi and I've read about
that and I was like I can put that in a
hunter
sounds like a good Arc right there
that's crazy dude what are you checking
up trying to find this monk thing I've
definitely heard about that celibacy
thing though yeah um
that's right
is this the thing that I was talking
about Jerry okay yeah so it's basically
you you naturally mummify you yeah
that's it they mummify themselves
willingly yeah and while they're alive
and if they're like cave or like they
don't go through with it they're not
worthy but they have to like starve
themselves yeah like in a in a like
coffin yeah for like how many days is it
or something to stay in there I think
it's something crazy and I can't
remember why yeah I feel very bad that
they stood 80 80 [ __ ] days or
something to do this and I can't
remember why they did it it's like no no
maintenance it's probably something like
spiritual no it is cinnamon or something
yeah I think I remember on this queue I
think they're talking about how like
they the I think it was the Japanese
government at some point was like Hey
can you can you just stop stop doing
this please this is really weird and
uncomfortable people don't like this
yeah people don't want your mind I mean
you know you know a lot of people praise
Japan for being a few cultures that
actually really hold on to tradition but
uh I mean maybe there are some
traditions we shouldn't hold on to well
actually I mean there's a lot of
tradition they didn't preserve for some
of them they're like all right yeah this
is kind of weird modernize this thing
yeah let's let's not do that yeah penis
vessels though the people's fine as [ __ ]
I want to go through it yeah that that
just looks like a laugh it's really
trying to meet up in Japan
sorry and I know and I know like in my
video we also found a temple that was
dedicated to the women as well I was
gonna say I was I I was hoping it would
be yeah we found a vagina Temple oh okay
just say vagina okay I didn't know if I
was allowed to say vagina we went to a
vagina
all right fine we went to a vagina
Temple it was awesome did you enter
through like a a you know something like
a fleshy yeah
going in
[Music]
no but what was cool was that like um it
wasn't like you know physically like
that but like it was uh symbolically the
the whole idea was that when you come
out of the temple it's like you're
rebirthing so you cleanse yourself in
the temple and then you come out of the
vagina entrance and it's like oh it's
like you're being reborn and I'm like I
thought that was pretty [ __ ] cool but
it would have been cooler if it was a
physical like
the physical parallelism one you
wouldn't want that uh yeah no one wants
that or needs that I I just I just I
just think about that and I'm like yeah
so like the the idea of reborn that
sounds like a cool spiritual kind of
Awakening in idea walking out of a
vagina and saying you're like reborn
that I don't know the imagery just like
the imagery just doesn't match with the
idea to me yeah of course
I love how uh in Japan it's like you
know they have these really super
sexualized things but then they're very
hush-hush about sex and other kind of
topics oh yeah it's like weird it's like
uh it's like oh we'll have a giant
Festival celebrating penises yeah but we
don't like gays it's not gay it's not
gay things yeah that's but that's what I
was wondering I was just like when I was
standing there at the penis festival and
I saw a little homerotic 40 dudes
carrying this giant [ __ ] I don't even
think the Mardi Gras does this
has anyone ever like questioned how
slightly homoerotic this is and like
Japan's making progress slowly with it
of course of course yeah I mean I think
it's just because it's it's not that
they I'd say that they it's not that
they don't despise gay people right no
no they just have an old system and
Japan is very slow to change yeah but
most people don't give a [ __ ] oh no of
course forget about that sure of course
and you go to any of these sex stores
bro yeah you know I don't give a [ __ ] oh
yeah if anything they're in the future
or something yeah yeah exactly a bit too
much they're a bit too far I went to uh
I mean by the time this is out it's
pretty darn I went to uh uh go to sex
store
um because Ludwig wanted me to get him
the idea of the video is that he gets me
a box of 500 with the stuff from America
that got America themed yeah and he
wants a Japanese themed box or right 500
of the Japanese stuff I've done some
cool stuff you know uh but you know I
had to go to the sex store I was like I
gotta give that because I'm thinking
content I want to give him content what
is better than content than half the
stuff in this goddamn stores yeah but
the problem is how do I get stuff that
he can show on a live stream yeah and I
found stuff well it was just weird
enough
no that's that's like vanilla from all
the stuff I found there was this one
like vanilla I'm thinking stream needs
again I found the
I found these things I'd never seen
these before I I know they've only
existed before but this is a this is a
new thing to me it was it was branded in
as face hole TM and it was just Anime
characters but there wasn't a flashlight
it was just an anime character and you
you do the thing to its face
way so it's like it's like a it's like
shaped like a mouth or something it's
shaped like a body and then you it like
it like curves like this like a natural
you know body you know you had to head
here yeah oh yeah yeah so it's like and
on the side there's like a 3D like
diagram cross-section of what it looks
like on the inside yeah and I guess you
just have to put your mouth in it and
then go all the way down the thing it
was [ __ ] wait so where is like is
like the neck hole or like the mouth
mouth curves
so like yo your pp's doing some
contortion
um right and they had like the they had
a it was like a package deal so you
could get this and then down below for
like 500 yeah and five bucks yeah you
can get some some of that lube for this
anime it wasn't any lube it was like an
injection Lube because obviously have to
get it deep in there right so it's like
a little [ __ ] needle yeah I was like
this is just too much this is too much
and sell the clothes they were selling I
was like my goodness I bought like a
fake camel toe something I don't know
who needs this oh fake Hamilton what's
the obsession with camel toe here what's
up with that what is the obsession with
that I guess some people just really
like it yeah I don't know and then I got
the sprays obviously of course yeah
armpit sprays men some of those things
panty sprays yeah well some of them like
I had to make sure the box art was safe
for work so there's a lot of them are
just sweaty girls and this is like who
see I've I've been through like here in
the store I've been through this yeah
yeah for years now like yeah this is
like going on shopping trips or Sydney
for like her next her newest video and
it's just like yeah this is this is just
normal now I every Walk of Life was in
that store buying stuff of course the
oldest man who definitely shouldn't have
been is definitely way too old advice on
this stuff but yeah props to you yeah
and you know a bunch of couples were in
there and a bunch of younger people than
me oh God I feel old saying there um
young people
I'm buying all like the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
putting it in my cart like yeah I'm not
weird and then I'm like this is really
weird this is really fun but that's the
thing right it's like I feel the the
best part about those kinds of stores is
like when you have a friend come to
Japan and you're just like yo show me
some like weird Japan
there was some other stuff yeah and the
one in Harbor right next to the station
yeah the Green Building yeah dude there
was this weird I'd never seen this
before it was a body pillow that had a
blow up portion to it and the and they
were like blow up legs yeah like this
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
attached to the body pillow I know what
I said he's got that why
because some dudes just want to grab the
[ __ ] legs yeah yeah
you know floaty combined with a pillow
yeah it's it's like as how as close you
can get to a sex doll as possible
without actually buying a three thousand
dollar sex doll you know there are
different tiers you know it'd be really
funny if you like throw throw one of
those into a pool and you just see like
a bunch of little eggs
because you know the body the pillow
part's gonna sing so it's just a bunch
of legs yeah there's so much here oh I
should not exist yeah at all there was a
Tenga that was bigger but of course it
was labeled the US Tenga oh yeah yeah it
was black
give me the exercise thing I I felt like
such a Chad rocking up to the stores
like one US Tenga for me please
no big deal whatever I mean I yeah I
mean got a nice awesome questionable
[ __ ] um on my tank of videos oh yeah we
did holy [ __ ] though the weight one was
my favorite one I [ __ ] love that but
also that would be like that would be
that would be an easy way to destroy
your dick as well it's kind of like
eventually wait okay so this is a thing
right so when I did the Tenga video was
gone yeah they they brought us like a
bunch I was like show me all the weird
[ __ ] I want to show all the weird [ __ ]
off I know like we got you and they
brought out this one which was in this
wooden like chest yeah basically
probably about that big right pick this
thing up heavy as a [ __ ] and I'm
like this is a this is a this is a tinga
right a little [ __ ] orb open it up
it's this metal I I how heavy was it was
like five ten pounds it was 10 kilograms
10 kilograms is this 10 kilogram metal
cover for your Tango and the idea of it
is that why would you Jo when you can
work out in jail yeah it's literally you
can lift
you're like jacking yourself off with it
like an Iron Maiden yeah yeah it's like
and it's like the packaging is just this
like [ __ ] rip dude just like holding
this thing I saw that there was a a
tengo workout package yeah yeah it is
yeah it costs 500 oh yeah I saw this
yeah after that I was like what the [ __ ]
he was doing workout yeah I mean the the
yeah the thing literally [ __ ] like
I'm working out
quagmires
Quagmire's ultimate form you know but
like it yeah the thing looked like an
Iron Maiden for your dick you know it
was a [ __ ] it was a [ __ ] sword
trap in a box you know like I can
imagine like this you know you're like
sore 20 and you just have 30 minutes
yeah
it's a pump 200 times without destroying
your dick because the thing is if you're
the next episode of euphoria yeah
because the thing is if you let it go
for a second it would literally just
crush your [ __ ] dick because this
thing's so heavy yeah and I'm like wait
and the guy was like unsurprisingly
they're not they're not for sale anymore
and I'm like yeah no [ __ ] I I saw a
full-on it looked like a pool pump that
had been like retooled into a sex toy
what oh straight up
like a very powerful dick pump and I
thought who the [ __ ] Austin Powers needs
no bro this is like combining four Dyson
brand new like v10s into one suck on Max
this is like ridiculous I'm like what
what is happening like what is what do
you need do you need like like the
[ __ ] uh the Teletubbies Hoover to
jack you off like what is going on I
remember I remember watching that
awesome the first Austin Powers movie
with the with the dick pump like a bit
and I'm just like there was a pump this
was a straight up like a like a full-on
jet engine suction but I remember but I
remember thinking when I was watching
that movie I'm like this is hilarious
this thing can't exist in real life yeah
and then a couple of years later I found
out no these things exist there's an
audience wait what's the point of Dick
pumps again I forgot just to momentarily
make you dig a little bigger right is it
really isn't it I think that's what it
is you're asking me as if I've used
could be yeah
this is
a dumbbell that's it yeah I mean some of
the time I respect the creativity some
of those tengas that we were shown on
the uh on the Tenga video was like way
too much like says some of them were
they had like if it's
a [ __ ] motor the auto rotates your
Tenga for you you know I'm sorry when
you're having sex you're not rotating
exactly you know what I mean like you're
you're not like oh hold on a second like
it goes on top of you
I got a new sex position it's called the
helicopter
get your fellow get your fellow uh
Speedwagon enjoy to hold on to the
ceiling fan and then get a ladder
like what do you like I don't understand
like the obsession of like it's like
it's like God did not decide that we
could make these motions exactly this is
these are not even make them with your
hands
like a Chinese food we are not allowed
to do these so when I hear that
technology is doing this yeah no no
because what if you get what if you get
to the point this has got to have
happened there's a guy out there in
Japan he's like I just cannot not if my
dick is not rotating yeah three three
rotations at least ten rotations a
minute like like what happens when that
happens
yeah that's definitely definitely
there's a dude out there there's at
least one I would like to argue many
tens and hundreds of dudes because they
have too much good sex toys yeah yeah I
think that's a problem they're too good
yeah they're too good yeah when when we
when we refer to like yo how many RPM do
you go up to when you jack off
you're like man I didn't enjoy the Tango
rotate you're like Bruno wrong RPM RPM
with uh repulsory 50 rpm a week I I go
100 at least yeah I saw that and like
you know how you see like some of those
ads sometimes where you just like try
out this game you won't you'll last 10
seconds or less you know that's actually
like real [ __ ] advertising for some
of the these [ __ ] sex toys man I
swear to God so Kai what's the purpose
of a dig pop
encourage blood flow
it's like a natural Viagra no kind of it
lasts as long yeah well obviously it
doesn't last as long but it's like yeah
it's it's it's it's the equivalent to
that yeah but no that's definitely
happened I mean I think there's even
like an issue right now where you know
some there are people who are addicted
to porn and everything like that and you
know they're so they're like less
sensitive now to actual real sex
sorry oh yeah I actually said I am
as well
I I would have I would have been but
hence she's been so garbage it's been
hard to do anything that is true recent
anti has been kind of whack not gonna
lie it's been awful yeah we'll save that
heads this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn you know boys using using the
internet without expressvpn is like
checking in your baggage at the airport
without a lock don't do that I mean you
think your stuff is kept private but you
never know who's going through I don't
know your 40 000 worth of camera
equipment
when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers isps can see
every single website you visit they can
legally sell this information without
your consent to add companies and Tech
Giants who then use your data to Target
you guys let me tell you why you should
be using expressvpn well for one you can
browse more anonymously on top of that
though it works on all of your devices
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your Wi-Fi can be protected
as well I've personally been using
expressvpn for years now and it's never
failed me and the ease of the app is
probably the best part so what are you
waiting for visit expressvpn.com
trashtaste that's
[Music]
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com trash taste and if
you use our link you can get three
months of expressvpn for free so go to
expressvpn.com trash taste back to the
episode is it is it is it weird that and
I've always found this weird and I know
I've pointed out many times because I
feel Japan is the only one that is so
open to that kind of [ __ ] but at the
same time it's just like no we don't
want to talk about it right because it's
like because it because I find it weird
that you can go to any Don Quijote and
there's just like an open section for
Daniel like it's not even behind a
curtain I feel like it's it's uh what's
the word where you're kind of
constricted uh like Society here is very
um what's the word when you're held back
a little bit um oppressed yeah a little
bit right like the the
people have to really hold back their
personalities a lot in Japan yeah and I
feel like that results in them just
getting [ __ ] wild you have to hold
back yeah when they when they get to
like let loose and do their thing it
feels like you know if you're gonna make
me work like 50 goddamn hours a week and
make me work on like weekends the least
I can do is just do whatever the [ __ ] I
want and if I want to have a good Jack
offset if I if I want to they're gonna
hold they're gonna hold back a different
thing is I want to do some weird ass
[ __ ] that I I have participated in the
society and done what you've asked to me
and I'm doing it yeah I mean and so I
feel like that's that kind of just that
letting loose is where it comes from a
little bit oh no definitely well I think
it's also the big reason why like a lot
of you know that side of the industries
for example like you know like the dojin
side of things that's why we get some of
like the weirdest like what the [ __ ]
type of ideas because it's like you're
yeah because in a daily life you're not
releasing it as often so it builds up
and builds up yeah or even discussing it
and so it builds into and tones into
something that's just like how the [ __ ]
do you think about that yeah right so
yeah at least see the people not talking
about it at all not wanting to engage
with it or going just insane and being
not insane but like going wild with them
yeah because like you know people people
still have thoughts you know people yeah
if there's no if you can't Bonk that
away then uh what are you supposed to do
you know it's uh I mean there's a lot of
things in Japan like even you know going
off topic going back to the fire
festival thing that you were talking
about full circle baby full circle yeah
I'm just like it comes back yeah it
seems like I've I thought Japan was like
really on top of it with health and
safety but it seems like to me it feels
like some things you have to go through
so many red tapes oh yeah just just to
get anything done but there are some
things in health and safety in Japan
that is just a [ __ ] free-frow and you
just kind of mush it up as you go along
and I feel a lot of those types of
things where the Japan is kind of just
like OHS what's that it's usually linked
to stuff that's just like well it's
tradition yeah so you know people have
been doing it for hundreds or thousands
of years and uh you know we're still
around as a society so yeah sure it's a
little dangerous but like you know it's
all in it's all for culture it's all a
tradition they don't they I mean you can
sue in Japan but people don't Sue as
much yeah not in the UK especially the
US people people love love a good soup I
think I think people get lawyers before
they get health insurance in America I
mean Japan you leave a bad Google review
and that's like worse yeah right but
it's like it's like it's like that's a
business Destroyer yeah like you don't
have to [ __ ] I'm not I feel like there's
not that much of a concern for that like
yeah if people get food poisoning here
they often don't like try and get you
know uh some um yeah we'll try to take
some recuperates yeah uh recoup any cost
or whatever from yeah the restaurant or
something that's true like food health
and safety here is actually very relaxed
yeah and it's very much just built on we
just we trust that everyone is doing
what they say they're doing yeah I think
I think the the Japanese mentality of it
is oh I got food poisoning at this
restaurant that's not on the fault of
the restaurant that's on the fault of me
who couldn't you know properly maybe I'd
like to think because because a lot of
like this is us well I mean my Japanese
side understands that because it's like
it's very much this mentality of I don't
want to inconvenience other people yeah
it's like my problems are my own and I
don't want to make it and I don't want
to drag people who may perhaps be
innocent about it yeah right so it's
like I totally understand why you know
they wouldn't like you know there isn't
like a Karen that just comes down so
it's like how dare you food poison me
sometimes you get a bad batch as well
like that that could be out of the
restaurant's control exactly yeah a lot
of the time it is due to this not
cooking it up or storing it properly but
you know it does happen and I can
understand that why you'd be like it's
just like I'm sick I'll be done I'll be
fine in the next day nothing you don't
need to make a big fuss about it yeah
exactly but you know there's a lot more
of a you know culture for that but also
you know I mean again the old uh old
traditions uh combined with the fact
that I think people are generally more
sensible yeah yeah yeah yeah
or rule we have in the UK or the US is
because somebody [ __ ] up yeah like
somebody was stupid enough and did said
like what if what if I bungee jump
without a car safety what if I run down
a hill with a ball of cheese yeah
exactly yeah this is why first of all
hello this is why we can't have nice
things yeah doing bungee jumping into
hours so fine you got to do it yeah I
want to how did you do it yeah it was
awesome safety awesome dude I I was like
you hear these horror stories of people
doing it in like countries where you're
like they don't have a great reputation
for health and safety yeah yeah you know
they'll be like yeah I went to this tiny
island in the middle of nowhere and
there was a dude who just had the bungee
and that was it yeah it's like I was
always you're always like attached by
like two wires not even just the bungee
like it's in like yeah yeah yeah when
you do actually do the jump it's just
the bungee right every moment up until
that you're you're connected with like
two three wires it's super safe and yeah
it was awesome dude I I still won't do
it though bro I want too much of a [ __ ]
I want to do a bigger one
well how big is the one you did uh [ __ ]
I think it was about 100 meters and
that's considered small it's generally
quite small for a bunch of jumbo right I
think the biggest in Japan is in gifu is
like 210 meters right right and dude
it's sick I want to skydive barking I
think
so I would like to bungee jump but I
think I would prefer skydiving yeah same
same yeah I just don't let the deer
being strapped to someone
well
well I understand you have to yeah yeah
yeah like that's just how it is like I
obviously once you get a license I can't
[ __ ] you you just start even getting a
license yeah do you see what I mean like
to me it's like I love the freedom I
just want to jump out of Lane by myself
I do I do I do want to do that yeah I
one day when I when I retire hopefully
at age like 50 40 you know I'm trying to
do the speed uh Felix speedrun of retire
before 40.
um I would love to just get like a
skydiving license and just be able to do
it and take it I just want to be like my
hero Tom Cruise imagine imagine being
like oh you want to go skydiving bro I
got you I'll take you yeah and it's like
you I literally literally the guy like
you jump and it's me yeah and I'm like
dude
how much of a [ __ ] Flex would that be
yeah that would be [ __ ] awesome and
then you could just Skydive whenever you
want yeah I mean but like you have to
invest rightly so hundreds of like I
don't know how many hours of like air
time to be able to get like get a
license probably I don't know
how many jumps do you need to get a
skydiving license or whatever I don't
know how it works can we have Google
there yeah dude the bungee was awesome
though I wanna I wanna be that but
instead of the skydiving I want to be
the oh you want to go on a yacht let's
go I got I got a license I got a boat
let's go I want to be that guy do you
need a license for a yacht I don't know
yeah you need it you need a license
in the boat license any boat some some
countries have limits for well in Japan
you need license for everything I assume
uh Kai has the answer for us
that's not that crazy
I mean that's a lot of jobs
if you were doing a jump every month two
years you've got your license it's not
very much sorry babe I have to go for my
monthly job I'm sure do you act a bungee
jump and I got the taste for it dude
you got the taste of gravity that one
that one second where you where you're
jumping and you don't feel anything yeah
that that's a rush dude what do you mean
because you mean when you hit
um before you hit the terminal terminal
velocity
I was gonna I was gonna go that fast
yeah I was gonna say like
you obviously have the bungee jump
attached to you yeah uh but it's like
dudes who throw it right yeah so for the
first second or so it is literally just
you falling yeah before the bungee kicks
in and it starts to you know stretch and
slow down that first second was just you
jumping is nuts and it's it feels insane
yeah because you jump and it's like holy
[ __ ] this is what it was would look like
if I jumped off a cliff yeah this is how
it would feel like just that that
nothingness and just the speed you just
feel like your gut's just like dude yeah
like your whole body just goes up and
you're because I dived yeah yeah so I
did three jumps and I I wanted to do
each one cooler absolutely you know yes
I did like a I did a dive the first time
and then a running dive the second time
then I didn't flip the third time wow I
was like can I do tricks and they were
like I probably shouldn't but you can
and I was like how do I do it
and then they were like all right so you
got to hold the bungee to your side
right and then you can do flips oh okay
otherwise the Rope will get tangled yeah
so and then also it turns easier so then
you can you can do it then you let go
and you want to just return back right
don't let it slap like slap your face
yeah so that was really fun but dude did
you do like the did you do like the Ezio
[ __ ] like that's right yeah yeah I
did like fish stuff I did yeah I did the
the [ __ ] swimmer die yeah [ __ ]
down oh my god dude the shots even the
GoPro yeah and the 360 camera's so cool
oh yeah it's awesome yeah I mean like
I've always wanted to go bungee jumping
and skydiving I've always been like uh
you know you you reach a age sometimes
because I love roller coasters you reach
an age where you're like vertical she's
just ain't doing it for me anymore you
know what I mean I never hit that point
I'm still scared you know like skiing
snowboarding the hardest slopes doesn't
do anything for me I need that Rush yeah
see it's weird for me because it's like
I've always had this fear of heights for
the longest time but in certain
situations I'm totally okay with it so I
don't think I'll be able to bungee jump
I think I'll be too much of a [ __ ] but
like you know for journey across Japan
we're parasailing and we were up like
and we were like no he [ __ ] hated it
he was [ __ ] his pants but I think
he's seeing him [ __ ] his pants made me
really enjoy it yeah you know what I
mean we did this one it's like I'm like
150 meters up in the air yeah if I was
by myself I would be [ __ ] there'd
just be a stream of [ __ ] yeah I was
flying down because I'm with someone who
is more scared than me yeah I was like
this is awesome I love it yeah okay just
bring Chris everywhere I'm just like
yeah I mean he's a little worse I'm sure
he's gonna talk about this one when he
comes on yeah like my God trying to get
him to do any of the like wait did he do
it no of course not no of course not
originally okay so there's three things
that you can do at this place it's like
you should go it's called gravity park
inside time it's [ __ ] awesome you
gotta drive there though
um so there's a bridge and a zip line so
you you zip line across and you walk off
the bridge yeah yeah a bit boring for me
the lines like baby it's like a baby
zipper yeah it's very small and then
there's the swing and the swing I also
found scary in the bungee really it's
literally a swing you sit there and then
a dude just drops you oh I've done the
swings bro and then you drop and you go
really [ __ ] fast and really close to
the ground way closer than the bungee
yeah swings and there's this man
holy [ __ ] was that terrifying and
originally when we made this video I
booked for Krista Dix he was like yeah
I'll do this swing yeah I think he just
envisioned our swings oh swings I've
been on a swing before because you can
do a tandem as well yeah we'll do it
together yeah and then yeah of course
when we got there Chris saw the swing it
was like oh well um well actually
um uh I don't think I want to do it and
I was like what do you mean I paid for
it it's like 150 yeah he's like no no no
no no no no no I don't want to do it
come on and then he was like I try I'll
do the zip line and right when he got to
the zip line I went first and I'm like
where's Chris and I can see him like not
getting in the ready position to go I'm
just like what come on man well he's
like chicken out of that as well no no
he was going to though in the video it's
really good you should watch it yeah um
it's it's Chris is having like a mental
battle I'm sure he'll come on and tell
us all about it right uh it was it was
interesting though yeah because the same
thing happened on joint across Japan we
were supposed to because we could only
go on pairs on this parasail right right
uh but there's only three of us it was
me you know Chris and nasty so one of us
had to go twice right and the guy was
like okay but we also have to like think
about like the weight balance and stuff
like that yeah and so immediately he
like looked at Chris and was like you're
going on twice
and he was just like yes of course
and then he does those are the first
time with me
[ __ ] his pants the entire time comes
back down he's like I'm not doing this a
second time
what I've always had was stuff that I'm
scared of the moment I've done it once
and I found that it's fine yeah I'm like
that's great let's do it again yeah
right but some people like I guess like
Chris or other people I've met it's like
they do it and they're like I never want
to do that ever again yeah what no I I
thought it was safe though like what but
that's the thing I I totally get people
who do it the first time and maybe they
just like hated it so much they never
want to do it again likes adrenaline
yeah
totally get that but there's a
difference between being like I'll do it
once and if I like it I won't do it
again and yes I'll do it twice it's
super easy and like exuding this
confidence and it's like and then
immediately being like Oh actually never
mind I don't want to do it ever again
I'm like just make you don't want to do
it it's fine like I'll fully admit right
here right now I don't want to go bungee
jumping like I don't even want to try it
because I think I'll just [ __ ] hate
it but I'm not gonna like it's not like
you're gonna like show false confidence
and being like yeah [ __ ] it's because
you haven't done it once yeah
you'll get the taste man I think when
you do things once a lot of the time you
realize oh this is not that scary right
right
I'd never call you like a beta for not
wanting to put yourself right doing that
exactly that [ __ ] is scary yeah I mean I
think the thing is with especially like
a lot of thrill rides thrill Sports just
in general is that I feel like you know
as a kid I think you're more up for
anything right because you don't have
this concept of danger in your mind not
as much anyway not as not as much so
like I remember you know I tried us I
tried our skateboarding and I was like
this seems pretty fun everyone everyone
seems to love skateboarding I had one
bad fall and that's all it took for me
to be like I don't want to do the same
yeah yeah no I hate this yeah and like
similar things I've heard so many
similar stories to people who've done
snowboarding skiing as a kid they will
go like [ __ ] Mac 10 or whatever I
don't [ __ ] know and then they have
like one bad fall and they've just never
recovered from it yeah mentally you know
it's that whole mentality of climbing a
tree and then you just all it takes is
one fall out of the tree and you're like
I'm never climbing that high up here
yeah yeah right and it's the difference
between the kid that learns to never
climb that tree again and the kid to go
ah that hurt let me try that again yeah
I would always do that if I ever [ __ ]
up I was just like all right well I
could have just said I was that kid
where it's like I fell out of the train
I'm like I'm never touching a tree ever
in my life yeah I could have died there
[ __ ] yeah exactly that's why I've never
had a broken bone in my body yeah yeah
exactly same I have so many bad Falls
skiing and snowboarding and I've never
broken anything luckily
right so it wasn't too bad yeah it
depends for me like I've had some bad
falls on a on a skateboard and a
snowboard and a skateboard like that
[ __ ] because you're on concrete yeah
yeah I've got some bad Falls you don't
just get like you get grazes as well
which is like the it's I [ __ ] hate
unless you don't get Graces on a
snowboarder exactly that's why I never
wanted to do uh [ __ ] skateboarding it
looked so scary yeah oh yeah like I've
seen some of the injuries my friends got
I was like you know what I'm a throw
Seeker but this just doesn't do it or
were they padded up uh they probably
won't padded up yeah well a few of them
are professionals now right I'll do it
to this day yeah but like but that's the
thing it's like I think there's this
like weird thing especially with like
skateboarding when you start off where
it's like oh [ __ ] I I don't want to be
that lame guy with like the knee pads
and the elbow pads
like because like all the cool kids all
the cool skateboarders are just like in
a shirt and shorts but it's like yeah
but that's because they're good enough
to the point now where they're not going
to [ __ ] hurt themselves they know how
to fall without injuring themselves they
know like how to get out of rough
situations and raw Falls right because
because they probably started off with
the pads like you still see
professionals wearing all the parts if
Tony Hawk can use pads and helmets then
you can use it yeah exactly okay exactly
I've always wondered you know like
parkour people yeah yeah how do you
master the role and not [ __ ] just
destroying your body you know when they
roll off like big jumps oh yeah and they
just like don't get any damage yeah it's
like do you just practice that indoors a
bunch on carpet full damage
they literally like avoid fall damage
and it's with this like this droll [ __ ]
that I've seen yeah how the [ __ ] do you
do that why are they practicing
gymnasiums right yeah yeah well I think
that it's uh like a combination of
practicing on gymnasium and just kind of
like upping your height slowly jumps
they hide they jumped on them like even
bro even this [ __ ] roll can't pump I
assume they don't jump off a building
straight away and be like okay either
you uh break your legs or you just don't
make the jump when you die I've heard
horror stories people like attempting to
to do like big jumps and stuff from
parkour right away because they're like
well this is how you learn
I've seen videos of like some Parkour
guys where there's like in some
countries there's specific gymnasiums
four parts oh yeah yeah and so much yeah
yeah I've always wanted to go along you
want to know the one sport I do not know
how people get into tag huh tag tag
extreme tag I've seen that show okay but
I can see that though [ __ ] uh is it
longboarding
on a road with cars on it my friend used
to do that I'm just like the people who
do this must be born without a Fear
Factor in their brain they took the
amygdala out yeah
like you must not feel fear to be able
to [ __ ] do this because Even's just
seeing GoPro footage I'm like nope this
gives me anxiety yeah yeah because if
you lose your balance you're falling
onto calm it's like if a car just comes
exactly right if there's so many points
of danger where you know car could come
uh you're going as fast as a car and uh
yeah it's kind of like it's like jumping
out of a moving car basically yeah
and you all you have is a [ __ ]
skateboard you go like 70 plus miles an
hour
you can't no you can't you can break
with your body yeah
but uh yeah like that's that's one thing
where I'm like someone must have been
crazy to invent this sport you know
there are a lot of crazy people out
there yeah yeah like you know [ __ ]
the concept of like someone like Evil
Knievel right it's just like yeah what
if I just like took a bike and just like
did a 50 [ __ ] meter jump off oh that
shit's crazy the people who do the bike
like Motocross points yeah like the
extreme motor crossing and stuff like
that it's like another world it's crazy
it doesn't feel real yeah because like
you have to you definitely have to be a
certain type of person a certain type of
thrill seeker
um I'm just wondering what kind of what
what what are the environments that
you're the type of kid right if we go
back to like the falling out of the tree
analogy people like that are the type of
kids who climb up the tree fall break
their arm and they go what if I break
another one
how many can I do yeah it's like it's
like weird jobs you're like how did you
get this like you know like deep sea
like cable fixing people oh oh yeah like
they they [ __ ] they I think you have to
like they you depressurize yeah like a
few weeks but you you're like on the
floor of the ocean fixing these cables
it's like Twilight Twilight simmers or
swimmers or something something insane
there's a really good documentary on
Netflix about a bunch of people in
Scotland how because they're attached to
like an umbilical cord yeah
um and I think one of one of the um one
of the dudes that Court got stuck oh
[ __ ] while they were because the weather
was was crazy up top and yeah throwing
the boat around pulling this guy around
the floor bed yeah and it's it's crazy
it's it's like such anxiety yeah and
it's just like this job seems like one
why why would you decide to do this like
I'm sure the pay is insane yeah but like
my God to go to the ocean floor and just
fix oil companies pipes hell no the
thing is the thing that's awful about
that is that you spend months just go
down there oh yeah because because it
because it takes so long to depressurize
it's
it's only financially viable if these
divers are just down there for months on
end for shifts right so you're just
living in a small [ __ ] pressurized
cave for months or need to go out to
[ __ ] fix cables at the bottom of the
[ __ ] ocean I'm like that sounds like
the most awful job I can imagine we
respect all of you like a huge [ __ ]
respect to anyone who does that you guys
are crazy it's like it's like that video
of the the guy who I think he works at
like a sewerage like facility and he has
to like go into the sewage pools to like
fix uh like draining issues and [ __ ]
like that it's literally just a dude who
dives into [ __ ] for a living probably
just can't smell it probably not he's
just like cuts off his nose it's like
it's like jobs where you like where you
get exposed to certain things you become
an object like chefs who get oil burns
on their hands so much that they don't
have any feeling left in their fingers
yeah right and it's you know there's I
think there's a few other ones with like
smell where you just get used to it you
just very quickly have to get it the oil
ones make sense because it's kind of
like you know when you first pick up a
Guitar you get like calluses eventually
either your skin hardens you know or
it's like morticians right that like
have to deal with dead bodies and you
just deal with it you just have to deal
with people we're [ __ ] good at
adapting yeah not me other people I I
think I'm good at sitting here and
talking I think you shouldn't
underestimate how adaptable humans are
oh no we are yeah just to get used to
something that you shouldn't get used to
oh God yeah I mean like look at how hot
is that
how do you get used to that
yeah because I remember I saw like a a
video about like uh this you know just
this mortician who just like goes
through his day and just like describes
his job and [ __ ] like that on the one on
um [ __ ] with his name wired oh there was
that one as well everyone [ __ ] loves
that yeah that one's that guy's awesome
there's a different guy as well yeah
yeah there's a different guy and he's
just like goes through like daily you
know occurrences of a mortician and it's
just like yeah so uh today I'm dealing
with uh two patients he calls them
patience I'm dealing with two patients
um that died recently and uh yeah
they're basically just doctors oh wait
how is it like title doctor or something
yeah I think so I don't know well it's
kind of like a cross between it's like a
cross between a doctor and a makeup
artist right because it's like you have
to fix the body up obviously yeah but
they also have to make the body
presentable or a funeral or a coffin
it's just like yeah it's just like
really cool because like when you think
of like mortician you immediately think
of like a certain type of person right
but then you immediately are just like
oh goth kid yeah the goth kids from
South Park right it's like but it's like
why would you want a job where you do
with dead bodies every day but then when
you actually like look into it you're
just like oh these people are just like
every other person yeah I saw one where
it was um that one the white dude who
mentioned something along the lines of
it just makes you appreciate life a lot
more yeah because you're working with
dead bodies and seeing grieving families
a lot and really doing your best to give
grieving families a really like
appropriate goodbye yeah yeah and in
that sense I can understand why you
would see it as like okay I like doing
this job because I like giving families
the opportunity yeah to have the kind of
send off they want and giving them that
kind of closure morticians are just
doctors with no risk exactly you have to
close the loop you can't kill your
patient if he's already dead
yeah I guess yeah I mean I want to thank
those people in the freezer are actually
alive and they accidentally finish them
off like cutting them open or something
who knows who knows that's a horror
movie you know I'm pretty sure that is a
horror yeah there is a horror movie like
that where there's someone who's like
frozen in the morgue thing yeah they're
alive and someone's gonna open them up
probably some kind of urban legend no
yeah because I saw I saw this tick
tocker as well who his job was like a
cleaner but his specialty was like
cleaning up crime
scenesis
yeah yeah and I'm just like it's just
the way he just talks about cleaning up
bits of brains so casually and I'm like
man [ __ ] Samuel Jackson didn't
keep his calling Pulp Fiction how how
are you how are you so chill how are you
so chill about it man it's I'm like I'm
a mushroom cloud making [ __ ]
[ __ ] those those are jobs that
I'm like is this okay for you to talk
about this and your philosophy films
this isn't film anything on the job but
yeah he recreates it I'm like is this
this is okay right like this is fine I
think it's fine he's just showing us
like people who film their tick tocks
and they're like McDonald's shift I'm
like yeah like like [ __ ] McDonald's
they're not paying you enough yeah but
like are you allowed are you allowed to
do this yeah sometimes the managers in
like the videos I'm like yeah it's just
why my my order of 60 nuggets is taking
20 minutes because Outback I'm just
hearing like
the ice me screaming
I've always wondered about that because
I remember like there was this ice cream
tick tocker who like worked at like one
of oh that dude dude I know isn't it
isn't it that I know exactly who you're
talking about from all these jobs yeah
there's like the guy yeah there was the
guy the guy who makes the ice cream on
the table yeah on the table it's like
it's like
I mean it makes different kind of ice
creams like the Cold Stone Creamery yeah
the Cold Stone Creamery guy yeah yeah is
that what he's called well no no no the
store and then there's the guy who does
the subway oh yeah yeah and it's
literally him but just a reskin
it's crazy right I know exactly yeah and
I'm just like which subway is this being
filmed at like what are you what do you
think owns the subway oh he owns his
family owns the shop oh okay so that's
like big pranks it's like you're double
dipping in revenue streams yeah I
respect it but if you just straight up
like an employee yeah you got the GoPro
on you're like so today I had this
customer that came in and this stuff
like hey hey hey hey we got an order
because sometimes you imagine being the
customer you just starts monologuing
like watching like a Nile red video
unfold behind you you're like Nile not
Nile not not now it's not sulfuric acid
it's chocolate chip now
I don't know it makes you weirdly
uncomfortable in a weird way yeah
because sometimes you see the customers
in there and I'm just like it's I would
I would be like stop [ __ ]
tick-tocking myself I don't give a [ __ ]
I want a goddamn sandwich yeah like what
can you make my okay can you imagine can
you imagine these Tick Tock is existing
in Japan like like a customer comes in
in a Subway or something in Japan and
you're like excuse me may I film a tick
tock while I'm making your Subway I
wonder if they ask I I kind of like it
though like I like the idea that I do
this I'm like can I have a can I have a
chicken nugget and a Big Mac meal it's
like so I mean this customer came in and
asked you for and I'm like yeah because
but the thing is right the thing is you
can clearly see in these tick tocks
they're using both hands so the customer
comes in and then there must be this guy
with a [ __ ] ring with his like phone
in front of his face and just like yes
he's like yes can I take your order by
the way I'm gonna be filming a tick tock
over your order if that's okay I would
like it though I think it'd be safe I'd
love to go to a fast food place and
they're doing it I don't know why I
think it's awesome like it's it's like I
hope that they have all the permissions
to do it so they don't get [ __ ] for it
and don't lose their job but yeah I
think it's awesome I love this trend of
I'm gonna film me doing my job like I
feel like every single job is
interesting it just it's just about
presenting it as interesting oh yeah
yeah yeah exactly like there's that dude
who fixes carpets just replaces carpets
have you seen that guy no dude just like
I'm not even remotely interested in any
of this but sometimes I'll just watch
yeah my favorite thing about Tick Tock
or this kind of [ __ ] that they do is
when they they add something they do do
something in the short or The Tick Tock
that is just immediately the only thing
anyone can focus on and it's has nothing
to do with your subject
so in this one carpet fixing thing he
for some reason he shows b-roll of his
fish
and it's it's a tiny tiny Fishbowl like
the ones you would get at like the
dollar store yeah that's efficient just
all the comments are like bruh for real
you showing us the fish that's being
like that's in like a David Blaine skit
like like all the comments are just
about this thing nobody is talking about
him fixing this carpet and there's a
bunch of other Tick Tock I can't think
of it off my head but you'll watch a
video and maybe they'll have like a
really big hand or something yeah and
all the comments will be like is nobody
gonna talk about the hand yeah like I
remember this one where this dude shirt
is like wedding ring yeah in briefly in
a shot and it was on so goddamn tight
who's doing something else and all the
comments were like this bro about an
amputate his finger and he was just
literally all that I love that that's
yeah that's my favorite part about take
time and comments and hence the the
funniness of it yeah what the thing is
like I think there's a whole sub-genre
of that on Tick Tock where it's just
like people doing things narrating about
something that's nothing to do with the
thing that they're doing oh yeah you
know and I think like ironically a time
lapse yeah yeah ironically I think what
started how this trend started was
probably like in the drama Community
because like remember like the good old
leafy days where it would just be good
old yeah the the the good old leafy days
where he would just be using like some
clips of Cs go surfing yeah and then
just talking about dramas like some [ __ ]
and I'm like why is the Cs go surfing
here what's that got to do with the
point of the video it's iconic people
but not people still do that people
still do that right all they've done is
just replace the CSO go the Cs go
surfing yeah and then they've replaced
the drama with just anything now yeah my
heroic trend is the uh it's like the
girls going if you had like two minutes
with me what would you do and it's just
something completely unrelated I [ __ ]
love this have you seen the one with the
Geo guesser dude oh yeah yeah you get
five minutes with me what would it be
this is Angola right here and then we're
going to Thailand right now
he always answers
what answers and then he goes to
you [ __ ] love it I just it cracks me
up the ones that are like tell me you
did this thing without telling me you
did this thing and he's like no anyway
so we're here in Sweden right now
I love this looks like Ecuador all right
got it [ __ ] I just yeah I think
there's genuinely some really funny tick
tocks there there's just so much crazy
oh my god dude
um [ __ ] I don't even know if I should
mention it so I I um
found this Tick Tock and
um
I won't give too many details because I
don't want to give it away and I don't
want to give them [ __ ]
um so I was you know I was none of my
own business one of my friends School
messages me yeah and he's like bruh look
at this I open the tick tock and it's
it's it's
um
it's like a tick tock where there's like
a giant age difference right between the
couple I think I know what you're
talking about and and I'm like oh that's
kind of gross it was like 70 and like
20. yeah okay I know I'm exactly what
you're talking about and it was like
like hey you know me I like all the
women you know how it is right age
difference you know I don't mean [ __ ]
but there's a limit there is a limit to
how listen if you're putting the guy in
there into a retirement home at 23 you
got stuff to worry I mean come on
so you know we're kind of doing this and
I messaged back and I'm like wow that's
weird he's like wait didn't you realize
I like real wait realized one he's like
oh that's the that's the goal we went to
school with and I was like what he was
like yeah that's the girl we went to
school with I'm like what I'm like oh
[ __ ] it is oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] and I'm
like oh my God and this Tick Tock has
like millions and millions of views
right right I was like what the [ __ ]
this is so bizarre this is like such a
weird timeline yeah I feel like I'm on I
was like this is weird because like yeah
no I know exactly how you feel because
like it's like when you discover that
like this one random person yeah yeah
that's no there's one random person who
made this like hyper popular meme where
you don't know where it came from yeah
is like someone who's not that far
degree of separation from you yeah yeah
like I had that recently actually like
uh do you know that one it's easy if I
just show you but like you know the one
where it's like the girl just being like
Oh look a dandelion must be the last one
of the season eats the dandelion no okay
so it's basically this like Ice Age one
and it's like really funny and like it
made its rounds all the way back to the
Ice Age binge I mean
I'm just like that's hilarious because
she just like eats this dandelion just
like spits it out and so I I and so my
sister and I share memes a lot yeah and
so I sent this one because I'm like you
appreciate it I say it's just as much as
me so I sent it to her and she's like
bro I went to school with her I'm
serious just like like she was like my
best friend in high school I'm just like
the [ __ ] and you never told me about
this you never told me that your friend
from high school made one of the
funniest Ice Age memes on Tick Tock like
what the [ __ ] and it was so bro hit me
up we can be best friends mom yeah I
want some of that cloud yeah it's weird
being a person who does stuff online and
then like you feel that like you're like
the only one in your friend group yeah
right yeah you know and you're like oh
my god what the [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
like remember back in the day where it's
like they said everyone will get their
15 minutes of fame or something I think
that's like coming becoming more true no
that's 15 seconds of Fame man that was
15 seconds of Fame that was something
right because everyone like most of the
most my mates they have like one claim
of something that's happened online
whether it'd be like oh I had a had a
post blow up in Reddit and get the front
page or something [ __ ] you know there's
always like something I think that has
happened where something you've done
online has just blown up out of your
control for good reasons hopefully for
good reason hopefully I'm on the front
page Why is it oh that's nice guys what
do you mean this episode is sponsored by
Harrys guys at this time of the year you
might be going back to school it's
wedding season or it's a holiday prep
okay we're all cutting it close this
season as we go straight from one thing
to another and with that incredibly
sharp razors and refills that arrive in
the nick of time Harry's is the official
sponsor of cutting it close I've said it
a thousand times and I'll say it again
Harry's is the only razor that I
actually use the first time I tried it I
was blown away and I love that it stays
sharp for like a million years after
well guess what Connor right now you can
get Harry starter set for just get this
three dollar reduce actually insane plus
you'll get a free travel size body wash
the set includes a five blade Razer
weighted handle foaming shave gel and a
travel cover a 16 value for just three
dollars by visiting harrys.com trash
taste boys don't waste any more time
comparing Brands Harry's has the highest
customer satisfaction survey in the
Shaving industry and they're still
offering a no risk trial don't like your
shave no worries it's on them so no
matter how busy things get stay fresh
with Harry's get your Harry's starter
set today and you'll also get a free
travel sized body wash just go to
harrys.com trash taste that's harrys.com
trash taste back to the episode do you
think the Geo guess a guy could like
have skills to work for like
intelligence agency or something like
that no no it's a different skill set
because have you seen how they learn
it's like you learn like oh look out for
the type of bollards in this country and
then when you find out the Bollard ah
look you've already lost me yeah is that
what a Bollard is no it's like the like
the [ __ ] things on the side of the
road that like you know where you just
are on the side of the road that like
line it sometimes you know like when you
land your bike against it or something
and sometimes like a pole yeah but like
not a big it's a Bollard it's a small
kind of stubby one like around like
waist yeah yeah yeah oh they're called
bollards yeah they're bollards I didn't
know that well you learned something new
every day yeah so you know um like you
know let's say every country has very
distinct Road patterns and bollards yeah
because you're a human being and you're
not weird and you don't look for this
stuff but obviously you know you can
game it and so while you're looking at
that you'll notice oh okay so if if
Africa has these type of bollards and
Road markings whilst you're studying and
learning this you'll also just happening
to look at Africa a lot yeah you know
you can you can just learn yeah but then
you you inadversely you gain so much
knowledge just about like every country
you become universally become an expert
in like maybe indirectly like the
infrastructure the buildings of like
every [ __ ] time yeah yeah if he if he
can recognize an image within like 0.1
seconds or something he can Garner that
much information that just means to
Garner that much information in such a
short amount of time that must be my
wealth of knowledge that he can be able
to like yeah yeah um but I imagine the
computer can do it better though if you
took a picture of any place fed into a
computer there's I bet it could probably
get it more accurate than this well you
could probably just like reverse Google
yeah yeah I mean you know there's so
much images of [ __ ] online you know and
you know these geoguesses are like you
know if they if the geoguessor isn't in
the country which are a lot of countries
oh yeah yeah you just have no knowledge
of that country yeah you're like Giga
brained at like Mexico but China comes
up you're like
I don't know yeah well it's funny
because like you I you look at something
like geoguessr and you would never
imagine that there would be people with
this good at just like knowing and
recognizing the world yeah true but turn
it into a game oh and people will break
the system you know what I mean oh yeah
as soon as there's a game and a high
score people you can inadvertently just
get skills that you would never ever
think about getting through just like
traditional education systems which is
such a good game like yeah like the
concept of it is really solid yeah and
it's like anyone can you know again if a
game is is able to be understood by like
my parents within like 10 seconds of
explaining it's a fantastic game yeah
and it's a fantastic viewing experience
as well like watching someone struggle
with Geo guesser is fun because you are
you have your own thoughts right like
you're like oh I think it's here or it's
the country of your residence yeah or
you're just like oh my God I can't
believe it I live here you know every
time like [ __ ] Luxembourg comes up
you're like [ __ ] you Luxembourg people
for having a country that looks the same
as every other country around it and
then that one luxembourgie in the chat
is like how Dave yeah laughs in high GDP
yeah no but like what was I gonna say
[ __ ] I have a but like I had a thought
and then it just like [ __ ] evaporated
I definitely do want to play G I guess
though dude you should it's so fun it's
it's as fun as you think it is like it
oh yeah it's like you're like you you
watch someone you play it and you're
like I think I'll have fun playing this
yeah and yeah and you do because it's a
fun game yeah because
could could you like one of the big
things right Geo guess is another game
uh language learning I think people have
tried to gamify language learning you
see that a lot in duoling yeah right do
you think there are like some skills
that just can't be gamified like
language learning
depends to the on the person I'd say
right I think some people can really
learn super fast that way yeah and other
people just will not do anything for
them yeah because learning languages is
is so hard yeah it's a completely
different side of like your learning um
compared to other stuff like learning
physics or learning this it's a whole
nother like it's a complete section I
think of thought yeah it's a completely
different type of skill that I think
just exists on multiple levels like you
know just just learning vocab and like
sentence structure is not the end or be
awful language right like you if you
don't have an understanding of how that
language is used based on the culture
that it the language comes from then
you're just like then you're no
different to a dictionary yeah I mean
English has always just been a
suggestion it's always been just a tool
to get whatever point we want to cross
and like everything is broken no no
because our languages have like very
rigid rules English is literally just
made to be [ __ ] construed into
whatever we need it to be yeah think
about half the show should we say in
English it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense yeah like and new words added all
the time but also the way that some of
the the old words are used are like okay
I guess like that that doesn't make much
sense but okay we'll roll with it yeah
like one thing that blows my mind is
where a language has a law in that
language that completely changes the way
like you think so I believe that like
there's a language that is using like by
the Aborigines in like Australia right
where instead of using directions AKA
you know up down left right and
everything oh they refer to it absolute
Direction in absolute Direction so by
having a language that is just
pre-programmed with absolute Direction
like north south east west you have to
like just have you have to like mentally
have a compass with you all of the time
so explain absolute direction from my
understanding it's like you don't have a
left and right hand you have a East and
West hand yeah if you're facing North
yeah exactly but if you're not wasting
if you're not facing north then you have
a north and south yeah exactly and it's
like that's just like oh my God like I
have to be aware of which way I'm facing
in order to tell you that I am holding
something in this hand exactly yeah
which absolutely like blows my mind but
that's just a thing also what happens if
you just trap them in like a box room or
something
maybe they'd have a hunch they just have
like a magnet in there
I I forgot I'm the whole English Point
as well you know because grammar is like
optional in English a lot of the time
yeah it's really not necessary for
English to function it doesn't really
need any grammar yeah as stupid as it
sounds
you can get it's all just about getting
a point across in English it doesn't
matter how you do it well I I think
that's true for like most languages
right like grammar is in like well like
sentence structure and [ __ ] or yeah you
can just break sentences oh yeah of
course and it works like in other
languages it doesn't work I I call it I
call it speaking Google search bar yeah
because like the Japanese is so context
heavy that that you messing up the
structure of a sentence could lose
context
in some cases but I would also like to
think that English does that as well
maybe yeah maybe if you said Pineapple
eat hungry then you'd be like who well
who is it you yeah me and Japanese can
be the same way I know that Welsh isn't
as flexible to be broken as English is
and I at least that's all I know and at
least the very little Japanese I do know
it feels that way yeah I mean I think in
some ways Japanese is like even more
flexible than English in some ways
um oh yeah because you don't have to
stress about who the subject of the
matter is in a lot of ways like in
English it's like I did something or you
did something yeah they did something
yeah but in Japanese you can just say
did something that you can just base
based on the context of that sentence
you have a pretty good idea of who or
what they're referring to how do you
know someone is learning Japanese they
use watashiwa yeah you know no one uses
no one says watashiwa yeah so you just
say yeah yeah yeah exactly it's it's
it's very it's very context everywhere
you know because we learn from it in
English where I say I am going somewhere
instead of just going here yeah it's uh
yeah I mean every language is different
and a lot of it I mean I
now that I've Speak two languages and
you're learning a third they're flexible
in like different ways you know I feel
like English has a lot of advantages
especially when it comes to just
expressing slang especially I I feel
like you can make a sentence with just
words that have never been made and you
can or like words that just don't
[ __ ] exist yeah and you can get your
point across very easily yeah yeah
exactly look at the North my dad uses
words and I'm like you just make [ __ ] up
yeah but I know what he's saying yeah
it's like like what you just like it's
just like instead of like
um you know I don't know you just makes
stuff up all the time it's so
frustrating is he making stuff up or is
he just saying something that exists
that you just don't know no no he's like
I can't think of a good example but like
everything has to be shortened or
construed differently but like some
sometimes it just makes sense you know
because it's the feeling you know like I
remember before did I have that huh does
Ty have that because last doesn't really
have that you can't really
we're just changing the words in the con
and you still understand the sentence
yeah nowhere nowhere near as much as
English because I remember like
I remember when you know people started
using the word drip and I remember like
the very first time I heard someone use
the word drip and not refer to like
water or liquid you know remember those
days
we're like I remember some I remember
like damn he got drip and I saw the
picture and I immediately understood oh
it's because he's talking about clothing
and I don't know why that just like
clicked in myself immediately but I got
it you know I I got it I immediately got
damn bussing I immediately got why yeah
you know like I never heard that word
before but like I understood the the
meaning of that word just by the context
it was being used in it was like it
wasn't just like me guessing it was like
for some reason that just makes sense
yeah that's I think that's just one of
the strengths of English is that the
vernacular is really easy to understand
if if you're uh if you have a native
experience yeah like you don't need to
be like ingrained in a certain like
click to understand that particular time
yeah yeah yeah exactly oh that's
interesting the advantages of English
English is very open that's why English
is one of the most difficult languages
to learn yeah well that's the thing
constantly making up new words and we're
constantly breaking grammatical I had to
explain like copium to a Japanese person
and I was like okay like this is a lot
yeah like I don't realize how and I like
when I explained this it's gonna it's
not gonna make it makes you sound stupid
it's gonna make me sound dumb but that's
just how it is like you we just use
words that don't exist and then we drop
them but like I don't know why we do it
yeah we just do this it's not until you
think about it or you have to explain it
to someone where English isn't their
first language like I remember I had to
explain to my Japanese cousin what this
was yeah and she was like what is this
and I'm like yeah that's a good [ __ ]
question what the hell is that it's like
they're air quotes but like how do you
explain how do you how you use it
specifically oh [ __ ] it's like you know
what it is like suspicious and you know
when to use it when you don't know how
to explain why that works I can't I know
how to explain it to someone who speaks
English but yeah okay but how do you
explain it to someone who doesn't know
the concept of what this is when a word
is sus that's how I would explain it
starts with the money and then I was
like wait now now I have to explain
what's up
suspicious yeah it's literally
suspicious
are you trying to make are you trying to
make Sasha more of a word than it is
this makes more sense because it's just
a shortening of the word suspicious
right but like if you were trying to
explain like to someone uh it's lit Fame
right like you're not gonna say like oh
oh it's a it's a family that's on fire
like no that's not what it means it
means something completely different to
what it acts like drip right yeah yeah
like how do you explain drip to someone
who's not an English speaker oh I guess
it's drip is easy to explain the con the
meaning is just someone who dresses
why do we use the word drip I don't know
see I don't know why we use it but to me
it just feels right it makes sense do
you have these words in Japanese that
come up with like the flavor of the
month words and leave I mean yes but I
feel a lot of it is derived from like
slang or internet slang that has some
you know uh derivation to it that came
from like some kind of like meme or
whatever like a lot of the words are
from like two-chan speak right where
it's like there's some posts from
[ __ ] the Linguistics that was just
like one guy started using it and then
someone was like oh yeah that's pretty
cool it's like sometimes sometimes in
English you just find words like drip
where
um it's like put on a piece of clothing
you've never worn before and it just
perfectly fits and you don't know why
but it just like it's just like yeah
that works why does that work I don't
know why xiaomi Vu yeah
not this [ __ ] again anyway I'm sure
there are some linguists in the uh
Records that can answer our questions
yeah but uh maybe some polygots through
like 10 languages let us know yeah yeah
but anyway there's that's been this
episode of trash taste boys look at all
the patrons though look at all these
patrons hell yeah they got drip I hope
so yeah
well hey if you understand what drip is
you know what drip is they know what lit
fam is they hey but if you like to
support the show go to our patreon
patreon.com trash test also follow us on
Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hit our faceless
Source on Spotify
yeah but yeah language is hard language
is very hard it doesn't make sense
language language language confusing you
know my brain hurt brain hurt all right
but anyway we'll see you guys next week
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]